[Musique]
bonsoir brice robin nagano merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france alors
selon la première ministre belge arlette
clé du succès du déconfinement sais je
cite le sens des responsabilités des
citoyens même ligne à kankan france même
petite musique ça veut dire qu'on compte
également en belgique beaucoup sur les
citoyens pour se sortir de cette crise
boxing varient des chiffres assez
horrible en belgique
beaucoup de personnes sont mortes et
nous savons que nous pouvons
écrasée est la courbe en belgique
ce n'est pas dû à l'action du
gouvernement car le gouvernement n'a pas
réussi à gérer la crise heureusement
nous pouvons compter effectivement sur
les belges et les flamands et les
vallons c'est eux qui ont réussi à
aplanir la courbe
donc je pense que le gouvernement doit
être très reconnaissant envers le peuple
ça veut dire quoi à l'instar de la
france vous manquiez peut-être trop de
tests de masques en allemand et la seule
chose qui a marché en belgique également
à l'instar de la france était le
confinement effectivement le
gouvernement a pris beaucoup de temps
avant de mettre en place les mesures que
nous avons évoqué après l'apparition de
ce mal depuis la chine depuis l'italie
ou l'espagne le gouvernement ne
réagissait pas il a été très lent à agir
et à commencer à lancer une production
de masques
ils ont également menti quant à
l'efficacité de ces masques donc la
population est assez mécontente
il n'y a pas de masque même si on vous
le recommande lorsqu'il s'agit de
prendre les transports en commun donc
nous voyons cependant que grâce à
l'adaptabilité et l'efficacité du
peuple-belge que la production commence
à se faire au niveau individuel des
entreprises disent qu'elles peuvent
produire des masques et nous commençons
donc à avoir une amélioration de la
situation mais ce n'est pas grâce au
gouvernement alors comme en france art
ouverture des commerces le 11 mai sous
strictes conditions en admettant un seul
client par 10 mètres carrés pour 30
minutes maximum comment vous vous
accueillez cette mesure est ce que ça
vous semble facile à mettre en oeuvre
avec un choc qui promet du tout je pense
que commerçant réussiront à appliquer
ces nouvelles bien sûr je pense qu'ils
sont très heureux d'enfin pouvoir une
ouvrière cas beaucoup d'entre eux se
trouvaient dans les situations de plus
en plus difficile financièrement les
gens n'attendent pas l'ouverture ils
achètent en ligne et les magasins
physiques se trouvait donc en très
mauvaise posture donc cette ouverture
est salutaire et je pense qu'ils
réussiront effectivement à mettre en
place à appliquer ces mesures
pour moi la réouverture des commerces
est un peu tardive même s'il ne faut pas
être trop rapide je pense que le
gouvernement a trop attendu car ils
sous-estiment et l'adaptabilité et
l'innovation des commerçants belges
je pense que la plupart des commerçants
auraient pu mettre en place ces mesures
il y a des semaines sans qu'il y ait
autant de pertes financières la plupart
des commerçants cependant sont très
heureux de toute façon de pouvoir ré
ouvrir et de revenir à une vie plus ou
moins normal alors justement la vie
normale ça passe aussi par la
réouverture des écoles pour la belgique
ce sera le 18 mai mais des modalités
pratiques doivent être définies en
fonction des communautés linguistiques
comment réagissent les parents en france
par exemple ça fait une polémique parce
que beaucoup sont sont inquiets beaucoup
disent que tout n'est pas prêt en termes
de sécurité
la belgique c'est un pays très complexe
nous avons eu beaucoup de hauts niveaux
de gouvernement
donc il ya eu beaucoup de confusion au
cours des semaines et des mois passés il
semble clair qu effectivement la
rouverture arrivera bientôt et les
écoles doivent rouvrir les enfants sont
un des groupes les moins vulnérables au
virus
la situation est très risqué pour eux
donc pour moi c'est une bonne chose
cette réouverture des écoles
je pense que notre système scolaire est
de très bonne qualité et qu'on réussira
à mettre en place des mesures de
sécurité afin d'empêcher la propagation
du virus
mais effectivement tout comme en france
beaucoup de parents en belgique sont
très inquiet certains ont d'ores et déjà
dit qu'il ne permettrait pas à leurs
enfants de revenir en classe avant que
le virus soit complètement maîtrisé je
pense néanmoins que cette réouverture
des écoles est une bonne chose les
enfants peuvent reprendre leur scolarité
la jeunesse ne dure pas toujours et il
faut revenir vie normale alors ya une
spécificité belge en chaque foyer pourra
accueillir ce sont trois quatre
personnes alors à condition que ça soit
les mêmes c'est assez cocasse on imagine
le casse tête pour les belges
effectivement ce sera un véritable casse
tête
j'ai reçu des milliers de messages de
personnes dans le pays entier expliquant
que leurs familles et dépasse le nombre
de quatre qu'il est impossible pour eux
de choisir quelle fille ce qu'elle fit
pourra venir quel petit fils ou petite
fille sera interdite de visite
il est impossible pour certaines
personnes de prendre de telles décisions
je pense que cette mesure
n'est pas très bien pensé et qu'elle
mènera à beaucoup d'abus que beaucoup de
personnes ne la respecteront tout
simplement pas et que la police ou les
personnes qui doivent observer
l'application seront impliqués je pense
que d'autres mesures comme par exemple
en allemagne où une famille peut en
visite est une autre et serait plus
intéressant est en tout cas moins
déroutant car à chaque fois que la
belgique organisent une conférence de
presse cela provoque plus de vagues et
de flou je pense que cette mesure n'est
pas une bonne décision
une mesure à la mode allemande serait un
meilleur choix
merci beaucoup de risques la gamme rog
d'avoir été avec nos députés fédéral
pour le brabant flamand merci à vous